n Please no
!
In addition, the Italian cuisine Aqua Pad's haiku that relaxes the body of the empty world
makes the taste dance
.  The sweetness of the vegetables crackles and crackles in your mouth
.
A
dish similar to pilaf, which originated in Turkish cuisine and is
cooked in
dashi after eating it.  If the grains stand up perfectly,
it looks more sticky, but that's because the rice was cooked in
an earthenware pot.
The heat is maintained and excess water evaporates.
Lend me a pair of Turkish food earrings.
Chano's two loops are pinch hitters
Trigger various horses
[music] The
pungent spice is also mellowly neutralized with soy sauce
Miho hits the taste of tonporo It's not
too dangerous, and
each collides violently  Ain make a
regular ear
car